pour ne louper aucune vidéo abonnez-vous
et activer la petite cloche
la feuille d'automne emportée par le
vent
en ronde monotone tombant toby non bon
je sais je ne chante pas très bien et en
plus c'est une vieille chanson mais je
trouvais que c'était une excellente
entrée en matière vous parlez des
feuilles des arbres qui à l'automne
change de couleur et là c'est un
festival
parfois elles deviennent jaunes comme
les feuilles de mon abri côtier
parfois elles deviennent oranges comme
cette érables du japon ou rose comme les
feuilles de ce fuseau quoi qu'il en soit
ça finira pour tout le monde de la même
manière totalement dénudée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça mérite un éclairage ça tombe bien
c'est un peu une histoire de lumière
[Musique]
merci les petites mains commençons par
mettre un peu d'ordre dans tout s'écoule
le vert d'abord une couleur vitale pour
les arbres les feuilles vertes
fonctionne un peu comme de petites
usines elles produisent des sucres que
l'on retrouve dans la sève dit élaboré
qui sait fut ensuite dans l'arbre dans
le tronc et dans les branches ce qui lui
permet de se développer
pour cela elle capte du dioxyde de
carbone le fameux co2 présent dans
l'atmosphère ça c'est les petites mains
elle utilise aussi de l'eau et des sels
minéraux des nitrates du phosphore du
potassium puiser dans le sol
grâce aux racines qui remontent dans
l'arbre et jusqu aux feuilles
la production de saab est d'abord et a
lieu dans les cellules spécifiques des
ateliers si vous préférez et nécessite
de l'énergie
je suis vert ya quoi les feuilles
utilise la lumière du soleil qu'elles
captent grâce à la chlorophylle un
pigment de couleur verte
en fait le pigment absorbe la
quasi-totalité du rayonnement sauf le
verre qui réfléchit jusqu'à nos yeux
grâce à cette énergie
tous les ingrédients précédemment cités
l'eau le dioxyde de carbone sont équipés
et les éléments sont recombiner pour
produire des sucres qui vont ensuite
nourrir la plante c'est ce qu'on appelle
la photosynthèse la photo quoi et la
photo synthèse il un peu dur de la
feuille
si la chlorophylle est aussi vital
pourquoi les feuilles jaunissent et
finissent tel par tomber et bien tout
simplement parce que ce qui est bon on
était les beaucoup moins en hiver
les feuilles permettent aussi à l'arbre
de transpirer l'eau puisée dans le sol
au niveau des racines ressort au niveau
des feuilles dans beaucoup de régions
l'hiver le sol est complètement jeunes
est impossible de faire le plein sans
compter que les cellules de la feuille
riche en eau sont très fragiles en cas
de gel l'augmentation du volume liée au
passage de l'état liquide à l'état
solide
les détruire et c'est d'ailleurs ce qui
se passe au printemps quand il ya une
gelée tardive
l'hiver c'est aussi la saison des
tempêtes si les arbres gardent leurs
feuilles
il offre une plus grande surface de
prise au vent ce qui les rend plus
vulnérables
il se déracine plus facilement et puis
il ya la neige aussi ça c'est une photo
de mon jardin lors du dernier épisode
neigeux si les arbres gardaient leurs
feuilles
toute cette neige si accumulerait et les
branches finirait par rompre sous le
poids de cette neige par conséquent
lorsque la durée des jours diminuent et
que le températures chutent les arbres
se met en mode hiver
il se met à vivre au ralenti et à faire
des réserves
les échanges entre le bois et les
feuilles c'est ce petit à petit privé de
ressources
les feuilles ne fabrique plus de
chlorophylle et les éléments nutritifs
contenues dans cette chlorophylle sont
recyclés et rapatriés vers les branches
et vers le trou d'autres pigments bien
présent depuis le départ à l'intérieur
de la feuille mais jusque là masqués par
la couche de chlorophylle font alors
leur apparition et c'est ce qui explique
le changement de couleur le jaune et du
augmente au fil rapidement que l'on
retrouve également dans le maïs est d'un
jaune d'oeuf le orange est lié à la
présence de carotène le pigment comme
son nom l'indiqué colorent les carottes
certaines feuilles produisent de lento
cian le pigment qui les fait rougir
malheureusement ça ne dure qu'un temps
le pétiole qui relie la feuille à la
branche fini par se boucher les cellules
qui le composent ne se renouvelle plus
elle dure six lots et les sels minéraux
ne peuvent plus passer la feuille n'est
plus alimentée elle se dessèche et finit
par tomber l'arbre entre alors en
dormance enfin pas tous
[Musique]
et de feuilles en aiguille on en arrive
aux conifères
la plupart d'entre eux ne se dénude pas
en hiver on parle d' arbres à feuilles
persistantes par opposition aux arbres à
feuilles caduques
attention entendons nous bien ces arbres
perdent aussi leur feuille ce que nous
appelons des aiguilles comme ici mais
pas d'un seul coup
régulièrement tandis que d'autres
repoussent à leur place de telle sorte
que l'arbre n'est jamais dégarni et ça
c'est très utile
c'est un avantage considérable pour la
reprise de photosynthèse quand les
arbres poussent dans montagne en
altitude
le printemps est plus tardive qu'en
plaine il peut y avoir de la neige
jusqu'au mois de mai elle peut
recommencer à tomber dès le mois
d'octobre la période végétative est donc
très courte en conservant leurs feuilles
toute l'année la plupart des conifères
peuvent donc profiter des beaux jours
dès qu'ils arrivent pas la peine de
faire de nouvelles feuilles de se
remplumer pour synthétiser des sucres
bon moi j'étais pas rester plantés ici
moi et j'ai des fois ya ramassé dans le
jardin
[Musique]
t
ah oui j'avais oublié en automne il ya
aussi du vent j'ai plus qu'à tout
recommencer
à bientôt
[Musique]
il y en a vraiment pour tous les goûts
et j'ai oublié un truc des feuilles qui
en automne change de couleur on parle de
hrw
or on parle d' arbres à feuilles
persistantes par rapport à la
chlorophylle un pigment un piment un
pigment c'est un avantage considérable
en conservant leurs feuilles toute
l'année
[Musique]